peut commencer tout de suite si vous
voulez très fort c'est quand ils disent
non si vous voulez avec la séquence star
du paf
j'ai compilé tout ce qui se passe
pendant l'échauffement les magnétos
pendant les pubs et j'ai envoyé tout ça
hop à la dammarie-les-lys sa carte green
side tp vous dites des moulins porte
secours de tous et bienvenue dans 50
secondes inside de pmp et on commence
tout de suite avec tiffany bon voisin
qui est passé à sa de serre et nicolas
pernikoff assez drôle maintenant il fait
chaud et cette année ne l'appelez plus
il s'appelle morini bosc
mais isabelle morini bosc j'étais très
aimé par les deux émissions ouais
évident pour tout de suite
tiffany cette fois c'est la bonne avec
nicolas ou pas j'ai eu mes nièces son
téléphone
tu sais je me suis fait des concerts
si tu fasses attention breaking news
qu'elle est vénéré lit un message très
important adressé à la première dame de
france
s'il m'aime moi j'invite bonjour
démission ces quatre et je vous adore je
vous embrasse pas et jamais deux sans
trois nicolas et tiffany vont-ils enfin
conclure ok tu sais que c'est pas pour
tout de suite
en tout cas ce qui est bien dans tes pmp
c'est que tout le monde peut s'exprimer
tu vas me faire chier twitter chien
comme eva va faire caca et on trouve que
tu étais cola qui chercha nouvelle photo
de profil pour un star mais c'est pas
gagné
regardes tu as bien ça non et on termine
bien sûr avec baba l'animateur le plus
honnête du paf est accordé une interview
sur des bases improbable avec des clubs
en france
radu vais le frère chante france une
radio que j'adore la chanson française
jade dort et lave les cheveux prochaine
dans 50 ou good inside tpp et en plus
c'est vrai que j'écoute que chante
france et joly et m radio mais en plus
c'est vrai qu'on fait c'est vrai et
c'est vrai mais bon les j'avais pas
qu'ils aient des ihm camions sur des
barques sert depuis quand ce n'est
interdit sur des barques et chante
franck barlet les adore mais bon là je
savais pas ils m'ont pris au dépourvu
peut-être que siri vous allez bientôt
passer sur champ france non oui parce
que vous respirez le talent ça tout le
monde le sait tout le monde est témoin
pour dire que si rennes monsieur respire
le talent soit tu respires respire quoi
la ducasse et s'arrêtant longuement et
tu vas continuer vraiment les gens très
sympas vous verrez ce qu'il a le talent
vous êtes un amateur et que c'est leur
productrice de maïs et on le sait on le
sait on le sait mais pour moi votre
conversion est tout tracé cyril c'est la
chanson vous avez sans le savoir créer
le tube de l'année en 2021 quoi je peux
vous assurer que là vous êtes déjà
numéro 1 sur toutes les plateformes vous
ne savez pas on regarde et derrière et
j'ai un petit cadeau pour vous si on
veut se mouiller après le succès
planétaire de son premier single i zal
adjoint il a la joie
[Applaudissements]
isales adjoint cyril hanouna est de
retour avec son nouveau titre
bof monique au point que beaucoup
accusent bouffe molecule beau poil que
hoffman cult of mac os x que en piste
deux retrouvez la version remix de
boufarik
[Musique]
moi en voiture
oh
il
[Musique]
mes jambes
oh
quoique
[Musique]
je suis possédé
j ai regardé cyril quand je lisais que
j'avais 15 ans et j'ai vu que dans mon
truc il y avait un bail mais j'ai un
cadeau
il faisait déjà un délire et un des gars
c'est le numéro un c'est il ya personne
avant vous qui a sorti un tube il est
déjà disque d'or c'est là qu'est ce que
vous n'avez pas les complet si j'adore
les compliments sans rien d'un ballet
fait comme toi on est des lives la
caisse cas où l'un voilà et du benjamin
castaldi
ouais d'ailleurs il ira voir son fils
qui variés dans un instant simon qui va
intégrer une émission de télé réalité on
va vous dire laquelle
oui cassiano ya du bernard montiel
d'accord et il ya du dossier sur toutes
les missions en général d'accord bon il
a rien si vous êtes si on va voir si
marc versa dans un instant quoi vous
allez voir pousser un peu la hockeyeuse
gentil le bouffon espace savoir que
c'est que l'espace on va se retrouver
l'homme à la star c'est bon sandrine aux
instants avec sacha l'image et la fin le
lundi qu'il y aura le fils de benjamin
castaldi y aura le 20 minutes médias et
bien sûr on va revenir sur balances ton
post est là faire des vaccins on va vous
débriefer tout ça et on a des nouveaux
éléments sur cette affaire qui fait
grand bruit cela faire qu'on appelle la
faire ou dire
[Musique]
votre programme avec pin up secret'
secret d'une peau parfaite pin up
tiraient secret' point fr
les allergènes et particules
microscopiques peuvent s'accumuler à
l'intérieur de votre maison
c'est pourquoi les purificateurs d'air
dyson capture automatiquement 99 95% des
polluants de votre air et nos
aspirateurs sans fil génère une
aspiration puissante pour les éliminer
de vos sols et surfaces les capturant à
l'intérieur d'un système de filtration
étanche à 6 couches pour vous permettre
de garder votre maison plus propre
découvrez nos offres divers disponible
sur dyson point fr longue journée
la boisson énergisante avec un taux
élevé en caféine sans taurine est un
délicieux vous coca cola l'hiver ton
énergie coca cola énergie en ce moment
vous n'avez pas le droit de voir votre
petit fils à son retour de voyage parce
qu'il n'a pas le droit de voyager ni de
venir vous voir sans masque
mais avec la banque postale vous avez
quand même le droit de l'aider à
épargner pour son prochain départ avec
l'assurance vie c'est ça être banques et
citoyenne
la banque postale
[Musique]
à cuir center
bien plus qu'un canapé votre nouveau
canapé cuir ou tissu est à prix
exceptionnel chez cuir center
profitez en dès maintenant
[Musique]
à
dommage qu'on attendait
[Musique]
grâce à villennes où on peut facilement
trouver des vêtements jouets et
accessoires pour enfants chine et de
bonnes affaires sur intel c'est facile
que le payement est intégré et sécurisé
fait le choix de la seconde main
téléchargez vintage demain sera créatif
engagé technologique
internationale
connecté étonnant demain sera vous
demain ce sera nous
ionis education group
26 écoles pour former les nouvelles
intelligence de demain chaque jour
trente mille étudiants le prouve
[Musique]
avec vertigo
nespresso a une nouvelle fois réinventer
les codes du café
sans système de cendres et fusion unique
sublime l'intensité des armes
donnant vie à une crime à d'exception et
ce quelle que soit la taille de votre
tâche
vertueux ne suivait pas les standards
changer les
nespresso what else allez cette année je
me lance je me mets au sport je mange
équilibré et je fais plus de sorties
culturelles
mouais bon soyons honnêtes et si je
restais enfin moi même pour faire des
vraies rencontres avec bad ou des
rencontres en bas de chez moi
des rencontres au grand air et surtout
sans filtre où je suis moi car c'est en
restant soi-même qu'on fait de vraies
rencontres
oui aux belles rencontres oui aux vraies
rencontres baddou j'ai quelques joueurs
d'entrée pour tous par le shérif une
annonce compliquée à formuler maman
vient s'installer de mal à nous qu'on
sort pas avec la mère des autres sinon
on fait la passe et avec une belle anna
folie digne d'une authentique pizza
napolitaine
bellaing napoli de wilson où elle met
tout le monde d'accord découvrez tous
nos épisodes sur notre chaîne youtube
itani non prévisibles rares
grave les méningites à méningocoques
peuvent faire basculer la vie de votre
enfant et de votre famille prévenir la
méningite à méningocoques ont c'est
possible parlez-en à votre médecin
[Musique]
sans surprise sans attendre sans
paperasse sans agios sans cravate avec
nickel fait l'économie d'une banque un
conte une carte un rib pour 20 euros
chez votre buraliste
parce que l'essentiel ne doit pas coûter
cher tous nos buralistes sur ni quel
point eu c'est les soldes chez gifi et
gifi va encore vous et connaît les
soldes j'ai fixé jusqu'à -40% jusqu'à
-50% jusqu'à -60% et même jusqu'à -70%
sur les articles signalés en magasin et
sur gifi click and collect offre
réservée exclusivement aux clients
relatives à l'habitude aujourd'hui ou de
février 2021 voir conditions sur gto.fr
j visiter génie à ce tetris de tête
assez des imprévus et votre again en mai
nous à l'école en revanche ça on en a
jamais assez
un beau jour dans une jolie forêt
nouveau tiguan on n'en fera jamais assez
pour la famille
[Musique]
et pour réserver un essai du nouveau
tiguan rendez vous sur volkswagen point
fr
waxman une petite faim avec 15000
restaurant sur des livres ou choisissez
commander vos plats préférés
il ya toujours des offres irrésistibles
des super resto des super prix alors on
se fait un délit verrons à ce moment sur
des livres ou la livraison est offerte
pendant deux semaines dès la première
commande
votre programme avec pin up secret'
secret d'une peau parfaite pin up
tiraient sécrète point fr
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
vous l'avez vu 19h43 question où
l'hygiène est sûr que c'est vivre avec
son temps
ils savent qui est dans le choix tu as
tes droits
thual abîme la début de soirée là tu
sais que tu aimes dans l'abîmé at il
bien où l on on ne brûle pas bon en 2021
même toit alors moi je sais même plus
qu'elle a noués ça fait des années qu'on
ait confié faire tu sors il fait noir tu
ressors y était encore nuit sur des
collèges et après son livre à la police
on va regarder bradeurs les deux là le
dernier jour et acheter des trucs chez
le père noël qu'est ce qu'il veut lui
j'ai une question pour benjamin castaldi
alors et là je vous dire les questions
oui mais il répondra jamais aux
questions
c'est quelqu'un qui a perdu énormément
d'argent au contraire 7 millions de
pensions alimentaires 1 3 million
d'hélicoptères ça tombe bien que vous
parler d'argent cyril parce que benjamin
vous pensez que cette émission c'est la
farfouille non mais je fais que poser à
faire pendant les pendants les plus
petits je peux la semaine dernière vous
avez tenté de vendre des parfums sur le
dossier était déjà assez grave avec ça
ouais
cette semaine vous avez récidivé avec
vos business à la molina l'expression
10,712 mais je tenais à la prononcer
personnellement je jouais pas pourquoi
je t'adore alors que vous demandiez nous
fait chier on regarde que vous vendiez
des choses sur eux comme ça en loucedé
je veux bien mais sur cyril sage accepte
pas aller il faut qu'il prenne un
pourcentage on regarde
mais qu'ils appellent un agrément de nos
jours et a besoin de me lancer
non qu'est ce que c'est un scandale
j'ai un ami qui a beaucoup d'amis mme
lagarde les îles abritent en effet bondi
de 25 ans dégagé ya un l'audience
c'est une vie qui à 52 ans j'ai rallié
se concentrait son centre au début je ne
dois pas de riposte est bien présent
jadore jadore jadore et bon j'ai pas le
temps moyen exceptionnel saint-pascal à
lui à tout prix faire de bonnes choses
oui dit me bernard comment ça va déjà ça
va bien merci
vous croyez tout permis bernard oui ça y
est parce que monsieur montiel côtoient
les plus hautes sphères du pouvoir c'est
un être humain des vidéos pour les
montrer à brides pas content je vais
vous dire un truc qui si les montres
donnera vais vous dire il est monté à
brigitte makrout ça n'a rien à voir
les cônes et sa loi c'est une jeune
fille j'adore car un restaurant mais
malheureusement à kolda qu'ovide
restaurant le sandwich au thon et
donnera sur la tête de ma mère elle fait
des bricks and off comme des briques aux
pommes de terre mais brigitte makrouds
verte et bleue dans lequel devait
laisser la révéla cru m'a bien sûr le
sais mais ça fait des années qu'on croit
des choses sur vous et il est sympa et
j'ai eu l'arrêt du lait sans plus un
islam il est sympa mais il croit qu'il
peut mal parlé à tout le monde
ah ouais ouais non je ne ferai pas comme
dirait bayer vous êtes qui vous vous
prenez pour qui
[Rires]
bernardino book
parce que c'est mignon mais il va
remonter plus loin des gros dégueulasse
c'est tabou fait encore
[Applaudissements]
la méditation
merde et on parle avec youtube la
méditation marin veut faire de la
méditation
si si si besoin de larmes de loot 2 vous
avez mangé un oignon arrêtez vous savez
que c'est vrai ce bâtard qu'est ce que
vous avez fait avec des oignons ben j'ai
mangé un oignon et je voulais faire de
la méditation avec bernard fois qu'il a
kiffé voilà et moi dès hier je suis déçu
et je vous jure mais pas un truc de ouf
joli mais il ya quelqu'un qui trace yak
akon mais c'est quand même c'est
celui-là qui est passé derrière moi mais
pas une odeur cyril puisque vous étiez
en train de nous parler on pensait que
c'était moi moi moi je pensais que
c'était vous voulez vous dire dernière
chose de pourri dernière chose énorme
dit au bénin oui on a vu encore cette
semaine que un amour entre nicolas
pernikoff et tiffany bonvoisin c'était
pas possible
ouais moi la semaine dernière je m'étais
proposés je me suis pris une fin de
non-recevoir bref
et quand ya pas de l'amour il ya de
l'amitié cyril vrai
tiffany s'est rabattu sur son voisin d'à
côté djamel talbi début d'une famille
est bon cela d'or montbel chili
qui sait
courir
[Rires]
dans ce fait reçu à l'être humain
mes yeux verts y sont sublimes non suite
au téléphone il avait son téléphone dans
sa vie
[Musique]
rires
et non sur un hectare et demi qu'il ait
dit non mais pas que si j'étais rentré
aux cassures et la vie normale à l'icom
[Rires]
[Musique]
ça va ça va ça va faire ajourner de
aller vers simon chaléat bravo pour bébé
[Applaudissements]